I want to talk to you about something we
discussed with David Muir yesterday
during our conversation about the
radical right and alt America Trump's
alt right whatever you want to call it
however you want to sort of paraphrase
it we've talked about how Donald Trump
since he started running for president
and during his presidency has used
signals that resonate with extremists
and white supremacists and racial
separatists and the most extreme
elements of society so one example was
America first right you hear the words
if you do a linguistic analysis
President of the United States says
America first what's the big deal right
it's just America first he's the
president of this country
this country is first but then you have
to understand the historical context of
that and you realize it that America
first mirrors a movement from the early
20th century that used the same term
linguistically it's not that extreme but
it is a signal to those who understand
it and in fact it worked when I
interviewed white nationalist white
supremacists whatever Richard Spencer
who by the way is now accused of beating
his wife anybody shocked to hear that we
maybe will talk about that tomorrow
Richard Spencer said we know that he's
limited in what he can just come out and
say but we see these as signals we see
these as wink-wink we get what he's
saying now Donald Trump is straight up
saying he is a nationalist now Donald
Trump has no idea what it means to be a
nationalist in the same way that he
understands almost nothing about any
political term but he now is using the
term and he's also using his catchphrase
not a lot of people save this I wonder
why let's take a look at the audio and
video but I am very proud of our country
we cannot continue to allow what's
happened to our country to continue
happen can't let it happen so I'm proud
and proud of our country and I am a
nationalist it's a word that hasn't been
used too much people use it but I'm very
proud I think it should be brought back
I'm somebody that wants to help other
countries of
but I also have to take it we have to
take care of our country we cannot
continue to allow ourselves to be duped
on military and also trade so I tweeted
about this in about this video and about
Donald Trump now saying I am a
nationalist and I got a ton of responses
and the ones that I was able to see
because they came from people who I
hadn't already muted on Twitter seemed
to be that were defending Trump seemed
to say what's wrong with being patriotic
and for your country and so that
immediately got me to the realization
that in the same way that Donald Trump
doesn't really understand what it means
to be a nationalist there's a lot of
people who don't understand the
difference between patriotism and
nationalism these are two different
things they're treated as if they're
synonyms but they're not patriotism
Patriot comes from 17th century French
it might actually come from an even
older Greek word patriotically means of
one's father it means love for one's
country love for where one came from
nationalism is a newer word it used to
be used interchangeably with patriotism
it has separated from patriotism sense
and nationalism now means exalting one
nation above all others and placing
primary emphasis on promotion of its
culture and interests as opposed to
those of other nations or supranational
groups nationalism has an exclusionary
element that patriotism when it's at
least properly defined doesn't have
there are people who consider themselves
Patriots who do have that exclusionary
attitude but in in principle that is the
main difference nationalism is often
modified with an additional word like
for example we could talk about Hindu
nationalism we could talk about in the
United States a common type of
nationalism is white nationalism in
South Africa there was Afrikaner
nationalism there's no white patriotism
patriotism just is patriotism we can
debate whether so-called Patriot doesn't
make sense you can have a serious
conversation about is there any sense in
being proud of where you by mere chance
happy
to be born that's a debate but where we
really can't debate is the reality that
patriotism and nationalism are two
different things if we list patriotic
leaders in in history we could say we'll
listen Franklin Delano Roosevelt was a
patriotic leader the New Deal Social
Security managing the post Great
Depression era patriotism who were
nationalist leaders of Notepad Ataturk
Ho Chi Minh Hitler kim ill sung from
North Korea Mussolini Gaddafi in Libya
this is not great company but it is
Trump's company Trump calling himself a
nationalist has meaning and I'm curious
who told him to start using this word if
I had to guess I would say Stephen
Miller was probably a factor in Trump
coming out and saying I am a nationalist
I typically don't buy into the idea that
Trump is playing three-dimensional chess
now but I think he is in this case
because well it comes across as him just
saying that he's a patriot by how he
worded it in the context of that video
calling himself a nationalist but it's
also a dog whistle right it serves to
you know bring out that base of
supporters who are white nationalist the
people like Richard Spencer and Miley
innopolis and those type of people who
voted for him well Anthony scaramouche
II one of the many former White House
communications directors he says that it
is a sort of dog whistle but it is not
to rile up the right that it's to anger
the left that it's a sort of trolling
take a look at what Anthony scaramouche
II had to say about this in the--
scaramouche you are you a nationalist no
I'm not a nationalist no he's he's not a
nationalist I mean he's saying that he's
a nationalist cuz he wants you to be
upset about it but he's really not a
nationalist I mean if you really
understand the historical word
nationalism and you understand what it
really means over the last 150 years and
we're about to go into a Veterans Day
which is the 100th year since the end of
the second I mean the first worst war I
mean it's just ridiculous he's not a
nationalist and if he wants to keep
saying it to upset people and we'll
probably do is double or triple down on
it that's fine but somebody should go
and you know knock on the door at the
Oval Office and say hey you're really
not a nationalist and when you say that
you're a nationalist what ends up
happening is you're gonna tune out some
of the people
you really need so scaramouche's
analysis of the sort of dark past of the
term nationalists is actually kind of
accurate but why are people constantly
telling us Trump doesn't actually mean
what he says and if scaramouche E is
right and Trump is saying things merely
to upset the people he's supposed to be
representing because I thought he was
the president of everybody how is that a
good thing how is stoking the fires of
nationalism to anger liberals something
that we should applaud the president for
doing send me your thoughts I want to
hear about patriotism versus nationalism
I want to hear what you think about this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show follow
us there and I look forward to hearing
from you I am thrilled to tell you that
one of today's sponsors is simple habit
calm slash Pakman where you can go and
get a seven day totally free trial of an
app that I use personally and love I've
talked to you before about the benefits
of meditation just simply sitting there
observing what it is that your mind
wants to do has been a great thing for
me we have so much evidence growing all
the time that this is just a good thing
for people to do and one of the best
tools you'll be able to find anywhere
online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the east and west
you can choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work
there are meditations specially crafted
to help people deal with anxiety or to
get focused before doing something
difficult and simple habit lets you keep
track of your progress by giving you
feedback about how much you're
meditating how many days in a row you've
been meditating it's a really
comprehensive and well put together app
go check it out you can try it free for
seven days
simple habit calm slash Pakman I've put
a link underneath this video